From actors standing up for writers, to getting
canceled by a superhero, filming "The Addams
Family" was a wild ride for everyone involved.
When it comes to Gomez Addams, there are two
names who immediately come to mind: John Astin
and Raul Julia.
Both actors helped to shape the beloved character
with a snappy dress style, a delightful mustache,
and total devotion to his wife and family.
Considering the Addams family members never
had first names before the television series
aired, the classic show all but shaped who
they were and how they would behave going forward.
However, it could have been very different
had Astin been cast for the original role
he was earmarked for.
Speaking to The A.V.
Club, the actor explained how he wasn't required
to audition because of his status at the time.
It also helped that he was familiar with The
Addams Family.
He had collected Charles Addams' cartoons
when he was in college, so he was particularly
excited to be a part of the show.
The role he was initially pitched was that
of Lurch — which Astin admitted seemed daunting.
This plan changed, though, after producer
and show creator David Levy contacted Astin
with another suggestion.
Astin told The A.V. Club:
Naming a child Wednesday isn't the most outrageous
parental act ever committed.
However, the case of Wednesday Addams is intriguing,
because it now seems like a fitting name for
her personality and appearance.
"It's me Wednesday."
Still, one has to wonder who came up with
the idea to name her after a weekday in the
first place.
According to a letter sent to The New Yorker,
Joan Blake claimed credit for the name after
a chance encounter with Charles Addams at
a mutual friend's party in the '60s.
Blake wrote in the letter:
According to the book The Addams Family: An
Evilution, Blake's story does check out, as
Addams mentioned it was a friend who suggested
Wednesday after reciting the line from the
nursery rhyme "Monday's Child."
There are many creators who despise adaptations
of their work.
But according to The Addams Family producer
David Levy, Charles Addams was nothing but
supportive of the classic television series.
Writing for The Los Angeles Times, Levy stated
the following:
However, Levy doesn't believe Addams would
have looked at the live-action films quite
as fondly, believing they missed the mark
of what The Addams Family was really about.
Of course this is simply Levy's thoughts on
the matter, as Addams passed away three years
before the 1991 film was released.
Perhaps if Addams had still been alive, he
might have had some input for the final product.
Cousin Itt is arguably one of the most beloved
characters of The Addams Family.
However, Itt didn't make his debut in Charles
Addams' cartoons, but rather the classic television series.
As per The Los Angeles Times, actor Felix
Silla, who played Cousin Itt, said,
Silla's sole purpose was to walk around in
costume for the scenes that required him,
while the lines for the character would be
dubbed in later on in the post-production process.
There was one problem: Silla's costume was
made from real hair, which made it extremely
heavy and dangerous since everyone on set
liked to smoke.
Fearful that he might be set on fire one day,
the producers changed his costume to a much
safer option, which featured synthetic, fireproof
hair.
The Addams house has become a critical part
of any version of the spooky family.
In various interpretations, it has taken the
shape of a mysterious haunted mansion, and
the classic television series employed a similar
approach as well.
While most of the action took place inside
the home, which was shot in a studio set,
the outside of the house was featured in the
show's intro, publicity photos, and the first episode.
It would have been possible to utilize a model
house for the footage, but there was an actual
Addams house in Los Angeles, California — well,
for a short while at least.
According to 21 Chester Place, a website that
covers the history of this famous property,
the production company used the house for
stock footage.
Since the company didn't own the property,
it employed an effects studio to add the necessary
details to the footage and photographs.
Unfortunately, the fabled Addams house no
longer exists, as it was demolished in 1967.
Lurch might look all doom and gloom, as if
someone stole his secret stash of chocolate
cookies, but there's a lot more to the Addams'
staggering butler than meets the eye.
The role of Lurch is a part that features
a lot of nuance and subtlety, something not
many actors can pull off.
Ted Cassidy not only delivered a fantastic
performance as Lurch in The Addams Family
TV series, but he also became the measuring
stick for the character that all other actors
will be judged by.
Surprisingly, Lurch was the first television
role where viewers got to experience both
Cassidy's voice and face, as he had only done
voiceover work before.
Standing at 6 foot 9, Cassidy had a successful
semi-pro basketball career, especially in
the college leagues.
However, the entertainment bug bit when he
secured a gig as a radio DJ.
Then, at the age of 30, he decided to give
acting a try.
Fortunately, due to his towering frame and
distinctive voice, he was deemed the perfect
person to bring Lurch to life.
"You rang, sir?"
"You're fired."
Taking one look at the patriarch in Charles
Addams' cartoons and John Astin's Gomez, it's
clear there are differences in their appearances.
As Astin explained to The A.V.
Club, the producers allowed him the space
to shape the character for the show and to
tinker with the source material.
However, in a separate interview with the
Television Academy Foundation, he explained
how he received pushback from the network,
as it wanted Astin to shave the sides of his
head to look more like the character from
the cartoons.
Fortunately for Astin, producer and show creator
David Levy backed his ideas and ultimately
allowed the actor to choose the path for Gomez.
Astin told The A.V. Club:
Astin believed this tweak to his character's
appearance further fueled the natural chemistry
between Gomez and Morticia on the show.
Considering how they are still seen as a guiding
light for couples around the world, it appears
as if Astin's decision was right on the money.
While John Astin's Gomez, Carolyn Jones' Morticia,
and Jackie Coogan's Fester may have stolen
all the limelight when The Addams Family television
series was released, the children also inspired
a generation.
Lisa Loring's Wednesday became a future goth
icon, while Ken Weatherwax's Pugsley became
the living embodiment of the macabre nature
of the show.
For Weatherwax, though, the role became more
of an albatross than a kick-starter for a
successful career.
Speaking to Bill O'Reilly, Weatherwax revealed
how he struggled to find acting gigs after
The Addams Family, since most producers only
saw him as Pugsley.
"I went out and, um, interviewed for several
roles but I was typecasted Pugsley."
The role also took a toll on his personal
life, as he experienced bullying from his classmates.
Weatherwax told O'Reilly:
Most five-year-old children are still busy
learning to read and write, not even giving
a second thought to what they want to be when
they grow up.
Lisa Loring admitted to The Sydney Morning
Herald the same was applicable to her, as
she had to learn how to memorize her lines
before she could even read for her role as
Wednesday Addams on The Addams Family television
series.
It certainly made no difference, though, since
the show changed her life and made her one
of the most well-known child actors in the
industry.
Loring revealed that she didn't have a comprehensive
filmography when she auditioned for Wednesday,
yet she still secured the role over another
young actor auditioning for the part.
It seemed surprising that Loring came out
on top since there's often a natural reluctance
from productions to cast very young children.
Loring claimed the reason for her casting
success was because of her uncanny resemblance
to Carolyn Jones, who portrayed her onscreen
mother Morticia.
Despite The Addams Family television series
finding its audience and becoming a runaway
success, it only lasted for two years on the
air.
In an interview with the Television Academy
Foundation, John Astin revealed how surprised
he was to hear that the show had been canceled,
though he knew the then-president of the network
had a slightly different sense of humor which
may have impacted the abrupt decision.
However, Astin expressed how another show's
debut may have also played a pivotal part
in the cancellation.
Astin told the Television Academy Foundation:
"You shallow brained simpletons, where's your
imagination?
Your ambition!?"
Astin appeared in Batman, portraying The Riddler
in Season 2 of the show, while Ted Cassidy's
Lurch also made a guest appearance in an episode.
There's sage advice that says never mess with
a winning formula.
But in the world of TV executives, they love
nothing more than to tweak and change things,
even when the show is a smash hit and everything
works well.
It turns out The Addams Family television
series wasn't immune to this phenomenon either,
as John Astin revealed to The A.V. Club.
The actor gushed about working with producer
and series creator David Levy and head writer
Nat Perrin, explaining how there was a natural
artistic synergy between all parties and how
it developed into a friendly working relationship.
However, the production company decided it
wanted to replace Levy and Perrin, so Astin
and Caroyln Jones intervened to get their
old crew back.
Astin told The A.V. Club:
While reboots are fairly common in both film
and television, The Addams Family television
series' unprecedented success scared off potential
suitors from trying to redo it.
The franchise lived on through various animated
shows and live-action films, but there was
a fear of reviving the series until 1998.
The New Addams Family featured a brand new
cast, with John Astin later making guest appearances
as Grandpapa Addams.
The show won a few Leo Awards in 2000 and
introduced a new generation to this kooky
family, but it didn't have the same lasting
impact or cultural influence as the original series.
Ironically, there's also a misconception that
The New Addams Family was short-lived in comparison
to the original.
That's inaccurate, though, since the classic
television series ran for 64 episodes from
1964 to 1966, while The New Addams Family
aired 65 episodes from 1998 to 1999.
Of course, the original series returned for
a reunion TV film and the cast provided their
voices for the characters in other projects.
However, The New Addams Family still holds
the distinct honor of lasting for one more
episode than its predecessor.